le projet de loi constitutionnelle
marquera également notre confiance dans
la capacité des collectivités locales de
métropole et d'outre-mer d'adapter elles
mêmes les règles qui régissent leur
domaine de compétence à la réalité de
leur territoire cet impact girondins que
nous proposons aux territoires en
suivant les recommandations du conseil
d'état
c'est aussi un gage d'efficacité et une
façon de réformer sans céder à l'esprit
de système
conformément aux engagements du
président de la république la corse
trouvera sa place dans notre
constitution ce qui permettra d'adapter
les lois de la république aux
spécificités insulaires mais sous le
contrôle du parlement